Mexico's foreign minister is in
Washington this morning for an emergency
meeting at the White House in response
to president Trump's escalating terror
threats against that country the
president's latest salvo calls for
imposing a five percent tariff later
this month with further increases to
come unless Mexico can stem the flow of
undocumented immigrants at the southern
border Mexico is the nation's top
trading partner and the tariff threat
rattled Wall Street Friday sending the
three major indexes down by more than
one percent even some Republicans oppose
the tariffs on Mexico Natalie Brand is
at the White House this morning Natalie
good morning good morning Anthony and
CBS News has learned that the Treasury
secretary and US Trade Representative
were initially against this new plan the
White House says they now back the
president's decision but last-minute
talks are being planned between the
Trump administration and Mexico's
foreign minister amid this latest threat
and new economic uncertainty stocks fell
sharply after President Trump said he
would impose tariffs on Mexico a
decision he defended writing in a tweet
Mexico makes a fortune from the US have
for decades time for them to finally do
what must be done we will put tariffs on
if they don't apprehend it is the
administration's latest attempt to slow
the record stream of undocumented
immigrants on the us-mexico border and
comes after more than a thousand
migrants were apprehended near El Paso
Wednesday we're asking Mexico to enforce
their own laws to help stop the people
coming in from Central America
Guiding ninguna little ocasion mexico's
president said he would not be provoked
and wrote in a letter to President Trump
social problems are not resolved by
taxes or coercive measures the tariffs
are set to kick in at 5% On June 10th
increasing by 5% every month through
October to 25% the White House said the
tariffs will be removed if the number of
people crossing the border comes down
immediately in a significant and
substantial number but did not offer
specific figures
Republican lawmakers have slammed the
proposal Pennsylvania Senator Pat Toomey
called using tariffs as a bargaining
chip a dangerous and risky economic tool
the new tariffs would impact billions of
dollars of goods from agriculture to
automobiles this is everything that we
import from our number one trading
partner Mexico the US Chamber of
Commerce said American businesses and
consumers will be the ones who will pay
so it literally is everything from
avocados to zinc a-to-z in terms of what
we import from Mexico consumers will
feel it when they go to buy tequila for
their summertime margaritas you'll feel
it when you go shop for a new car
farmers will feel it in the retaliation
and lawmakers also warn that this new
tariff plan could jeopardize passage of
the new trade agreement between the u.s.
and Mexico and Canada the u.s. MCA which
the Trump administration is now trying
to push through Congress this summer
meanwhile mexico's foreign minister says
he will be meeting with Secretary of
State Pompeo this Wednesday here in
Washington Dana Natalie thank you